well today was a very fun day with the
choose your journey winners we start out
with rock climbing sand ziplining some
camaraderie and learning about where
these folks are from and what they like
to do I feel like when you're doing
something that is fun and enjoyable and
and and they are - that's in their
wheelhouse it really brings out more of
the true personalities so I just feel
like it's a much much deeper connection
with the fans than just static meet and
greets and things that are traditional
we entered it because I wanted to live
longer and healthier and do things that
my husband does that I never ever did
knocking things off my bucket list my
fear and all this other stuff big fan of
the company like how their cars have all
them on Facebook when they saw the
consciousness behind you know that at
least for some bars you know let alone
come out here and do this school to me
like the name for the brand and I'm kind
of racing so I have to get school I
should jump right in like we were
climbing and she got on the hard routes
and showing us how it's done
nitrus bakery is all about getting
outdoors it's the energy for life's
great journeys so what are those
journeys and where is it gonna take you
and that's what we're doing here today I
mean we're getting out with being active
so we're really just doing fun things
that represent us and
you